Toby is in HR which technically means he
works for corporate so he's really not a
part of our family
also he's divorced so he's really not a
part of his family people keep calling
me a wonderkind I don't even know what
that means
I mean I know what it means it means
very successful for your age
so I guess it makes sense but
it's a weird word
so I just got the facts closing the sale
and uh it's big
it is really big congratulations thanks
congrats nope I didn't I just logged it
in all right try to be a team player
here Jim
all right well it already went through
don't worry about that
hello
hey Ryan it's Jim look man I don't know
what's gotten into you lately but you
know what I really don't care because
you're trying to get rid of me and I bet
you think I don't care enough about this
job to actually fight back but you're
wrong because I do and I will so you can
keep trying to push me out of this place
but guess what I'm not going anywhere
would you do me a favor and connect me
to Ryan absolutely
foreign
hey Ryan it's Jim you know what totally
disregard that last voicemail because
you obviously have your hands tied
good luck
if there is even a whiff of unionizing
in this Branch I can guarantee you the
branch will be shut down like that the
unionized in Pittsfield and we all know
what happened in Pittsfield
it will cost each of you a fortune and
legal fees and union dues and that'll be
nothing compared to the cost of losing
your job so I would think long and hard
before sacrificing your savings and your
futures just to send a message
if you have any further questions you
can direct them to
to Michael I don't understand that after
15 years of service here
I have to get in the car and drive to
New York in order to talk to you that
doesn't seem right to me
that doesn't seem fair and I think
that I've earned more
than that
yeah
you're right yes I get it I get it
Michael okay here's what I'm gonna do
okay we will move some money around
and I will personally see to it that you
have your party
you have your figs I will be in
attendance it's going to be great
how's that
I quit
what
Michael you have no idea how high I can
fly
so you are the lawyer Mr O'Malley I know
a lot of lawyer jokes I love lawyer
jokes well it's probably because you
don't get them
when I said before that I was king of
forwards you got to understand that I
don't come up with this stuff I just
forward it along
you wouldn't arrest a guy who's just
delivering drugs from one guy to another
I'm a little bit agitated Michael what's
the problem the problem is that
I am the boss and apparently I can't say
anything
well that that's my that's true in a way
you can't say anything Where's the Line
Where's the Line Jan do you need to see
the video again Michael I've seen the
video he talked the whole time no it
didn't
what
attention everyone hello uh yes I just
want you to know that uh this is not my
decision but from here on out we can no
longer be friends
and when we talk about things here we
must only discuss uh work Associated
things and uh you can consider this my
retirement from Comedy
and in the future if I want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression I will no longer ever do any
of those things
does that include that's what she said
yes wow that is really hard
you really think you can go all day long
well you always left me satisfied and
smiling so
that's what she said
come on hey Jim can I get a um hi
hi
I need to run down if your clients can
you get that to me sir yeah okay
what the hell is a rundown
I just need that run down by
as soon as possible okay just get it
right yeah gotcha of course
I'm gonna dive in to the rundown I'll be
exhausted because it's like a triathlon
did you want to close this
we'll keep it
just faxing
my dad hey run down I want my old job
back I want my old parking space back I
want a Sebring I don't like him anymore
and I want Charles gone I'm not firing
Charles he's very valuable that's very
kind of you to say Dave I need him gone
no
okay then I want Pam back
oh you already have a new receptionist
sales
thank you Pam's not a salesperson yes
she is
at the Michael Scott paper company and
it's Heyday that's right okay
continue and Ryan
cost under Mifflin hundreds of thousands
of dollars Michael Ryan David I don't
care if Ryan murdered his entire family
he is like a son to me
foreign
[Music]
oh hi David
long time no talk
through the temp agency actually
yeah
I got that
I I know that
David
you don't have to yell
David can can I just
let me just tell
me okay
right
office okay
okay
on the phone right
please hold
he just made the list
okay Michael
what is a business
is it a collection of numbers and sales
reports sure but as you know David and
Jan it is much more
[Music]
life moves a little slower in Scranton
Pennsylvania that's the way we like it
because at Dunder Mifflin Scranton we're
not just in the paper business we're in
the people business
let's meet some of the folks who make
the Scranton Branch so special
this is Stanley Hudson one of our
talented salesmen an African-American
father of two Stan Lee's dedication is
no doubt one of the Hallmarks of the
foundation of the business we're hoping
to build our basis on
yeah I shot a bunch of footage around
the office edited it together on my Mac
I was thinking about entering into some
festivals probably won't you know not
what this is about but
and finally Pam Beasley look at her look
how cute
not bad at all
as the receptionist Pam is truly the
gateway to our world
well I hope this gave you a little taste
of what life is like here at Dunder
Mifflin Scranton what it's like to walk
a mile in Oscar's shoes or try on
phyllis's pants
next time you're in town give us a call
stop on by I'm sure you'll be greeted by
a big smile and how you doing pal maybe
even one of Angela's famous brownies
and you'll know
that you're home
[Music]
questions